[Applause]
[Music]
hey there visual politic Community we
have realized a serious oversight for
more than 7 years we have been releasing
videos every week about the most diverse
places and topics however in all that
time we have forgotten one country
Portugal but that ends today known for
its famous Navigators and explorers such
as go de Gama and Ferdinand mcgillan
centuries ago Portugal became the
largest Empire in Europe that was until
the crown of Castile reached America yet
these days it is among the most backward
countries in Western Europe in fact this
is a circumstance it shares with its
Southern Mediterranean siblings Spain
and Greece and it is certainly nothing
new either Portugal's history is a
history plagued by instability and many
crises without going any further we have
just recently learned of the resignation
of its prime minister who is being
investigated for corruption
the Dignity of the duties of a prime
minister are not compatible with any
suspicion about integrity good behavior
and even less with any kind of criminal
act Antonio Costa former prime minister
of Portugal in fact as you will see in
recent decades resignations have become
almost a national sport in this
country of course it's not all bad but
do you know what its history teaches us
especially the most recent events that
with hard work you can get out of any
tight spot in fact for many Portugal has
become a clear role model for dealing
with new crises we could even say that
the terrible financial crisis of 2008
That Shook the whole world finally put
the batteries into a lethargic Portugal
of course in the last year we have also
seen new stories like this thousands of
people demonstrate against High Cost of
Living so just when it seemed that
Portugal was beginning to overcome all
its major problems 2023 has dumped
another bucket of cold water on it and
so we on visual politic have been asking
ourselves a few questions how did
Portugal become an economic Rising Star
what was the price it had to pay for it
why are the protesters once again taking
to the streets of the country today we
are going to answer all these questions
and we are going to do it with Jake the
new member of the visual politic team
take it away
Jake into the
abyss
many if not all of you already know that
when World War II ended fascism did not
disappear from Europe at least not
completely and yes I imagine many of you
are probably thinking of franchisco
Franco the Spanish dictator who was in
power for 36 years however did you know
that despite lasting for almost 40 years
this was not the longest dictatorship in
Western Europe to find the longest
lasting one we have to take a closer
look at today's protagonist
Portugal the Portuguese dictatorship
that began in 1926 became the longest
lasting in all of Western Europe its
leading figure Antonio the Olivera
Salazar an economist who began as
finance minister to the dictator Oscar
de fragoso Kona became the dictatorships
first minister in 1932 his project the
eston noo or New State prioritized order
over the new economy which meant a lot
of censorship and also the imprisonment
of many activists and political
opponents despite this he at least
managed to keep the country's economy
afloat albeit at much lower rates of
development than those throughout the
rest of
Europe in any case after being
incapacitated after suffering an
embolism in 1968 the dictatorship would
see its last years under Salazar's
successor Marcelo katano who had to deal
with the nationalist movements in the
Portuguese colonies in Africa and also
with the 1973
[Music]
crisis so what was the result in the end
after 48 years the dictatorship fell
after the uprising of armed forces
officers in April 1974 this movement
became known as the Carnation Revolution
however from that moment on Portugal
launched down a murky path full of short
presidencies until 1986 when along with
Spain It joined the European economic
community that was a real turning point
for the next 20 years the Portuguese
economy grew at a rate of almost 3% per
year it wasn't cause for wild
celebration but it was a 180° turnaround
Portugal like countries such as Spain
experienced a huge spiral of wealth and
modernization nevertheless in 2008
tragedy struck 1 December 2008 it's
official recession since December 07 14
December 2008 Eurozone enters recession
for first time in history on our sister
Channel visual economic we have already
told you about the origin of this crisis
and how it swept the financial system
and took down Banks like Layman Brothers
but for today's country the situ
situation was even worse in 2008 the
Portuguese economy not only saw its own
real estate Bubble Burst and its economy
begin to collapse but within a few years
a huge public debt crisis was also
unleashed the Portuguese State already
far more indebted than the European
Union average suddenly had to take on
massive amounts of
debt in 2012 just four years after the
outbreak of the crisis public debt
already exceeded 120% of GDP as you can
see the problem was quite similar to
that which occurred in most of southern
Europe the crisis was much bigger than
anyone expected the Portuguese
government responded by trying to feed
Demand with more public spending a kind
of hypercaloric formula where instead of
calories you add debt interest and more
debt however this approach was
completely useless in the end the Prime
Minister yose Socrates had no choice but
to cut back because plain and simple the
public coffers were completely empty in
a way the country was unraveling it was
then that the key figure of the
Portuguese recovery came to power Pedro
pasos
Colo pasos Colo then leader of the
conservative PSD won the 2011 early
elections by a wide margin the
Portuguese people chose him to carry out
one Mission revive Portugal in order to
do so the new government had to make a
difficult decision the same one that
Greece and Ireland were forced to make
to accept the bailout from the European
commission and the international
monetary fund specifically Portugal
received 78 billion but on one condition
the country would have to embrace
economic austerity Colo then began in
the darkest moments of the crisis
between 2012 and 2013 to take the
toughest decisions for example he cut
spending on Education Health and
economic Affairs by 7% drastically
reduced redundancy protection at a time
when unemployment was breaking records
with levels of over 15% and froze both
the minimum wage at 500 as well as the
salaries of civil
[Music]
servants the question is was it a smooth
process not at all as you can imagine
faced with such a scenario what always
happens in these cases occurred
protesters began to flood the streets in
spite of everything in 2014 after three
long years of widespread economic
suffering the country began to see the
light it was in any case not an easy
starting point 16 May 2014 Portugal
emerges from bailout poorer and still
far from recovery but do you know what
from then on Portugal was not only
concerned about recovering completely it
also wanted to armor itself against
future crisis what are we talking about
well let's get into that right
[Music]
now developing
muscle after bottoming out the
Portuguese economy started to grow again
it did so at a more leisurely pace of
2.3% on average between 2014 and 2019
but even so unemployment managed to drop
to just over 6% and so although pases
coo did not manage to renew his mandate
his government did manage to get the
economic situation on track and prepare
the foundations for the recovery a
recovery which by the way the current
prime minister the Socialist Antonio
Costa later took credit for as you know
there's nothing new Under the Sun the
fact is that the Colo government not
only only reduced social spending but
also pushed for plans such as the
Simplex program to reduce bureaucracy in
the public administration this measure
was crucial in recovering FDI for
instance check it out it also managed to
start reducing public debt which between
2014 and 2019 fell from
133% to
116% we are not talking about any
Miracle here as you can see the crisis
hit very hard and the post crisis data
are nothing to write home about but what
can I say given the history of Southern
European countries this change from
inertia was exciting to say the least so
let's just say that the achievement here
is that the Portuguese government
managed to stabilize things 29 November
2018 Portugal repays to the IMF all
loans from the 2011 Financial bailout
the international organization lent more
than 26 billion at 5.8% interest
stabilize things and also improve the
country's own economic foundations and
pay attention because this was key why
well because in 2020 the pandemic
arrived and this time this time Portugal
was not among the stragglers but among
the
leaders in 2020 its economy fell by more
than 8% but in the following 2 years it
grew by 5% and 6% respectively and not
only that the country managed despite
everything to further reduce public debt
to 113% in 2022 in other words in 2022
Portugal's public debt ratio was lower
than it had been in
2019 visual politic viewers for many
analysts Portugal has become a kind of
role model at least a realistic
attainable imitable example thanks to
tax incentives regulatory improvements
and an active attraction for foreign
investments unemployment these days is
relatively low the economy is growing
and its macro parameters are improving
unfortunately this is not the whole
story
tourism and investment equals
crisis remember when we told you that
Kio reduced bureaucracy so that Portugal
would receive more foreign investments
well as you can imagine this was not the
only measure he took to attract foreign
investors KO realized that he could get
a two for one if he played his cards
right not only did he have the
opportunity to attract more investment
but also to fight one of the country's
biggest challenges growing demographic
aging yes Portugal is also one of those
countries that is set to have very
complicated decades ahead of them the
population over 60 years of age now
accounts for almost 30% of the total
population a percentage that will
continue to grow steadily over the next
few years well the fact is that Pasa Kio
introduced two controversial measures
intended to attract investment while
reducing demographic pressure Colo
introduced the famous golden visas and
startup visas check it
[Music]
out introduced in 2012 the golden visas
granted residency to foreigners in
exchange for an investment of €500,000
or
$535,000 in their first s years they
managed to raise more than 3.4 billion
thanks to the arrival of thousands of
investors with stratospheric incomes
from China Russia the United States and
several Arab Nations who wanted to enjoy
a residency and even the possibility of
obtaining European nationality while
enjoying the significant tax breaks that
this scheme granted them the startup
Visa was prompted to attract Founders
and companies that could present
projects with the potential to reach a
value of
€325,000 or an annual turnover of more
than 500,000 within 3 years although it
did not Grant the possibility of
accessing Portuguese nationality it did
have the tax benefits that also applied
to the golden visas which is why the
creation of startups in the country
skyrocketed to the point of leading
entrepreneurial Improvement throughout
Europe visual politic community it is
undeniable that these visas were able to
help boost foreign investment however
All That Glitters Is Not Gold these
visas not only brought foreign money
into Portugal but also helped fuel a new
crisis the housing
crisis you see with the economic
recovery the zero interest rate monetary
policy and also the international Visa
scheme the price of housing in Portugal
has skyrocketed for example in Lisbon
the capital the average price for
renting an apartment is already around
€2,000 that's around
$2,100 this alone shouldn't be a problem
in fact depending on where you live it
may sound pretty good however remember
at the beginning of the video how
Portugal was almost last in per capita
income in Western Europe yep that's the
problem Portugal has a GDP per capita of
around
€4,000 and a minimum wage of €
760 now do you think that with those
income levels Portuguese people can
afford a rent of €2,000 in Lisbon the
truth is that it's complicated often
beneficiaries of taxfree programs such
as golden visas remodel a house but do
not occupy it many times those
properties are sold again and again and
that creates Distortion in the real
estate market and is one of the causes
of the housing crisis Luis Mendes
geographer and housing researcher in an
interview to BBC Mundo 30 May 2023 of
course the lack of housing has more to
do with land and construction regulation
than with visas but this model has
contributed to skyrocketing housing
prices and it has not even been the only
ingredient that has contributed to
worsening the situation tourism has also
had a lot to do with it in cities like
Porto for example houses designed for
temporary visitors that is tourist
departments already account for four out
of 10 dwellings in the city so the
Portuguese locals are struggling to find
affordable apartments to live in
obviously in countries where Supply is
limited if demand grows prices Skyrocket
and that explains news items like this 1
April 2023 thousands protest in Portugal
over housing crisis so what was the
outcome well the government of the
Socialist Antonio Costa began to take
measures for example it established a 2%
cap on price increases in new rental
contracts and even promoted the
obligation to rent private housing that
was empty look this is what the initial
bill presented by the Portuguese
Socialist Party said landlords will have
100 days from receipt of a rental
proposal from municipal authorities to
rerent a vacant property in a habitable
condition housing Bill presented to the
public in March 2023 on the this project
homeowners would be required to inform
local authorities if a property became
vacant the local authorities would then
be able to make rental proposals and if
the process lasted more than 100 days
and the housing was still empty the
municipalities could rent it forcibly at
the price they themselves set they would
then sublet the properties to other
people as public housing in the end
however this measure was more diluted in
the law ultimately approved by
Parliament it applies only to properties
that have been vacant for more than 2
years and are located in coastal areas
even so it sets a clear precedent I can
already tell you that investors would
not like it one bit and that's not all
the new housing regulation has also
established hard limits to tourist
Apartments including a new extraordinary
tax of 15% and not surprisingly the
golden Visa program has also been
eliminated we're therefore talking about
one of the most radical housing policy
approaches ever seen in all of Europe
and that is precisely what explains this
news headline 21 August 2023 president
of the Republic veto's Mass vivenda
program of course in Portugal the
presidential veto is not definite the
law went back to Parliament which
approved it and the law came into Force
at the beginning of October even so many
Portuguese citizens are skeptical that
this plan will become established why
for one simple reason Portugal is in the
midst of a deep political crisis
since Costa managed to revalidate his
post in the 2022 elections with an
absolute majority he has had to deal
with 12 resignations of senior officials
of his government due to various
scandals something that earned him two
motions of censure by the right-wing
block and if that wasn't enough we came
across the surprising news we mentioned
at the beginning of the video Antonio
Costa prime minister of Portugal resigns
after being investigated in corruption
case indeed the latest information
suggests that it was an error by the
Portuguese prosecution that confused the
minister of economy Antonio Costa Silva
with the Prime Minister Antonio Costa so
it seems there is no case against the
former prime minister even so you can
see the enormous political instability
that exists so we are almost almost back
to square one Portugal has improved some
things but just when it seemed to be
betting on a business attraction model
is suddenly taken a new turn in the
opposite direction that's the thing
about Latin countries they tend to fix
scratches with more cannon shots in any
case this is the story of how Portugal
managed to become one of the latest
European Rising Stars the question is
will it manage to remain so will
Portugal manage to fight the housing
crisis without ruining the national
economy and what would you do to combat
this problem leave us your impressions
in the comments and let's start a debate
and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to visual politic if you
haven't already done so all the best and
see you next
[Music]
time